now we just heard that a man has
appeared in court and been remanded in
custody charged with murder and
attempted murder following the
Nottingham attacks earlier this week
let's go straight to our correspondent
Tom Palm into who's in Nottingham Forest
this morning uh so Tom just update us
with what happened
you can see live pictures here from the
rear of Nottingham magistrates Court
where the police van
or the custody van with a police escort
is about to leave the building this is a
court hearing that has just happened
inside Nottingham magistrates Court
where
the man accused of three counts of
murder in relation to the events of
Tuesday Morning in this city has just
appeared in court
31 year old who was asked to give his
name that name he gave us valdo Mendes
which is slightly different to the name
given by the police earlier in the week
but he is accused of three counts of
murder and also attempted murder as he
leaves
the courts complex here in Nottingham
with two police vehicles escorting him
through the traffic in the middle of the
city he appeared in a gray t-shirt and
gray tracksuit bottoms gave his name as
valdo Mendes which as I say is different
to the surname that we were given by the
police yesterday he said he had no fixed
address and he gave his date of birth he
was stood in the dock with his arms
crossed flanked by two security guards
and the case because it is so serious it
involves those three charges of murder
it has been adjourned to the crown
courts here in Nottingham until next
Tuesday at 10 A.M so valdo Mendes the 31
year old accused of three counts of
murder and also
charges of attempted murder remanded in
custody here in Nottingham this morning
and he will appear again on Tuesday of
next week at 10 A.M at the Crown Court